so I'm really excited to talk with you
about Archie something I was really
fascinated with while watching it was
how Pitch Perfect your Carrie Grant
accent is um I was really Blown Away by
that I would love to know if like what
went into your dialect process um for
training for this you always feel a bit
embarrassed to talk about how the
sausage is made I mean there's a bunch
of stuff to do with trying to look and
walk and talk and sound like him and uh
I don't know if it does it take it away
from the audience know how it's built
I'm not sure it's a bit like giving a
magic trick away
um so I mean most of what makes me look
a bit more like him than me is just
brilliant makeup and hair from Li
Headley and P to the costumes and all
these saval Ro tayor and all that stuff
but I did I was a little bit frightened
of the voice obviously because people
think they know what his voice was like
wrong most people are remembering Tony
Curtis and Some Like It Hot who's doing
a parody and other people who did
mimicry and stuff which wasn't really
him at all it was an exaggeration but
nonetheless I watched the films and I
just with and I work with a diet coach
and we broke him down he was doing some
strange identical musical pattern every
time he spoke literally identical kind
of intonation pattern I thought nobody
talks like that you know when you spill
your coffee in your lap in the morning
there's no way you go I look very
familiar there's a kind of literally a
musical thing so I searched in vain for
an interview I couldn't find anywhere
the equivalent of this someone where was
having a chat with something just wasn't
anything God bless her gave me uh all
the DVDs and audio tapes had made but
that was him doing what I did
obsessively which is filming his kid
just a Cas microphone but mostly not um
and I was slightly despairing about it
not knowing how to proceed and then I
because I was doing a lot of other
research reading all the biographies and
business meeting minutes and uh other
people's autobiographies when they met
him um I came across this interview that
felt like a transcript because sometimes
I give an interview and I read it and I
go couldn't you tidy my ground up it's
clear that you're just transcribing my
own looping syntax and stuff I thought
that's a transcript and I tried to find
the journalist but he wasn't a
journalist and it was old and I found
him and it turned out he'd been a
student journalist in 1986 and he'd got
in touch with Caron's representative
then he hadn't been an actor for 20 odd
years so he wrote to someone in the vain
hope that maybe he' get an interview
because the University was doing a film
festival and he got a message back
saying call this number on Saturday
morning so he called on Saturday morning
Barbara answered he went hello and they
went hold on I'll just get Carrie and
Carrie Grant came on the phone well he
was at the University radio Department
to make this call and uh the first thing
K Grant says is you're not recording
this a you better not be and he goes
well I was going to he goes no don't I
don't want you to sometimes they end up
all I just don't like it he's all right
he gested to his friend to stop and then
they had this hourlong conversation
really you know roaming all over the
place uh very interesting and then at
the end uh when he got off the phone his
friend went I mean obviously I did
record it and he went what he said yeah
I'm not going to stop the interview and
he hadn't played it to anyone in 40
years and I tracked him down and I
begged him and he said who are you why
he wanted he was very suspicious and
very cautious and I persuaded him that I
was authentic and and wouldn't play it
to anyone else because out of respect to
car Grant he hadn't made it public uh
and he gave me a copy set up a private
YouTube link and that is the basis for
the voice so he's much a little bit more
English than he is in the films but much
more importantly you can hear something
like the speech pattern but it's much
more wide- ranging actually much more
plaintiff sometimes slightly higher in
Pitch sometimes I've work with movie
stars who come in and redo their voice
and octave down you know High fluttery
laugh um and then and I could hear sense
of being misunderstood I mean he was 82
was the last year of his life he's
talking to a 22- year old but still
sometimes he gave status to the 22y old
because he was a bit bothered by him not
understanding or or or not respecting
just I could hear the fault lines
basically I hear human being stretching
all the way back to the abused and
neglected boy and I heard a man who was
settled at that point in his life um a
whole bunch of colors that you didn't
get from the movies so that was my load
St I used that uh as the my Touchstone
throughout the you know filming and I
had it in my ears all the time when I
needed brush up well that's remarkable
and it really comes across um in in the
series um something I also thought was
interesting you know both you and Carrie
Grant have a connection to Bristol you
went to the University of Bristol he was
born in Bristol did you find as you were
like doing your character research that
you had little touchstones other little
commonalities with him that helped you
kind of bring him to life on screen Co
you always do that I mean you know as an
actor I mean one of the great things
about this very rare as a male actor you
get to do full chameleon
disguise often but men just don't get to
do it so there was something about like
almost like mask work by looking so
different walking and talking so
different but you always find things uh
that you have in common so the fact that
he code switched the fact that he became
whoever he felt other people wanted him
to be so that they would like him so
unlovable he' been so neglected so
abandoned abused well I didn't feel that
growing up my behavior as an adult
wasn't as Extreme as his was either but
I moved when I was a kid and I was very
self-conscious about my accent like he
was I changed my accent overnight I went
to college surrounded by very very parsh
people I changed my accent overnight
there to were quite sure uh often in
groups where I belonged or if I belonged
and would want would want to belong so
badly that I would somehow adapt my
personality he was a male escort who was
in New York I mean he was uh he learned
to be whoever he needed to be to survive
not just to survive literally because he
was starving a lot lot in his life but
also to survive emotionally to not to
feel like maybe this would be the family
where he belonged maybe this time it
would be a thing where he could be
welcom to establish himself so I
recognize that codes switching thing and
and he's an actor so that desire to
please that that dissonance between who
he was on the screen who he was in life
I've played lots of tough guys well I'm
hilariously UNT I mean you know you
couldn't get more of a
physical um and and then most of all I
think in terms of his the big sweep of
his life that he found himself he began
to find himself when he became a dad you
know no one ever loved him enough
because he he knew somewhere that they
would eventually leave him like his
mother had left him like his father had
left him like his grandmother so no one
Whatever love he got from people and he
got the worshiper most of the world that
felt fake felt like he didn't deserve
and the people in his inner circle just
couldn't love him enough until he had
someone he could love and then he
started to find real healing through
going I belong here whatever else I am
anywhere else I don't really know if any
of that's real what people think of me
what I think of them but this place
right here next to this person I will
always belong and and
I care for getting bit emotional I felt
that when my daughter arrived this is
where I will always belong I always
belong to to her oh that's very sweet um
yeah something else that you know I
think actors get it's very hard to segue
off that because it was like such a
poignant such an actor sorry um but you
know something that actors get asked a
lot it's like what do you bring of
yourself to a role but I'm curious with
how Larger than Life Carrie Grant is in
that way that he is trying to always
adapt and be whoever somebody needs on
you know in a moment were there any
aspects of Carrie that you felt like
kind of stuck with you after you wrapped
oh Christ no a lot of murderers as well
and all kinds of I don't know you know
space captains I mean no he was he was a
deeply troubled man if he was around
today and was humble enough to seek help
he would have every single acronym
labeled you know to his he'd be OCD ADHD
PTSD you name it AA all of it um so
uh my job is to try and forget myself
some actors AR like this my job is to
try as much as possible to make a clean
slate of myself to program in everything
that ever happened to him all the things
he wanted and needed and thought and
felt and then to start the scene and
forget everything you can't be thinking
about I'm not thinking about my past I'm
a product of my past but think about it
so you hope that if you do all the work
somewhere maybe in your sleep or maybe
while you're doing some other things
it's it's bubbling in You're Building
these temporary foundations that will
hold for the length of the shoot and uh
and then do the scenes you know the it's
written wonderfully by Jeff and I had
Diane's ear all the time or Diane had my
ear and then I'm oppos brilliant Laura
Aman Laura Amman who played young Diane
who was so Nimble and on her toes and
and so fresh in every scene you didn't
quite know uh cuz she spoke to Dian
separately I speak to D and we you
didn't you didn't really know what the
other person was going to do in the
scene if they'd be happy sad angry
crying laughing avoiding you uh like
marriage like life and um so having done
all the work uh I forgot it and lived in
the scenes I'm the kind of actor that
forgets myself entirely I like
forgetting myself entirely so I don't
think I brought much of myself to it and
I don't think I brought any of it home
my wife and kids wouldn't put up with it
no would don't probably for the best
with
how you know what they say people hurt
people really damaged really badly
damaged although he could fake it well
for the world even Fake it Well for some
of the people in his life like the way
that he wooed and seduced Dian Canon
over the course of a long period of time
because he was older than her dad she
wasn't interested really but eventually
he won her over and then as soon as he
got her as he said to her agent on the
phone she's not coming out of this house
till she's broken definitely very
interesting to see how you know these
men that we put up on P pedestals this
really helps to kind of break that down
and be like they're just like any
anybody else you know troubled and
having flaws and um like everyone else
but worse the more famous the more they
need to be famous I'd say probably by
the way not just men what anybody needs
and drives with that level of force and
passion to to getting famous the more
likely is that the the fault lines in
the cracks are
enormous I agree completely um as we
wind down on this interview I did want
to ask about one other project of yours
that came out this year that everybody's
talking about which is balers Gate 3 you
voiced in ver gorach that game has
occupied far too much of my time this
year but I am curious like what was the
process like for that and doing that
that voice rle I do lots of voices I
love voices in fact one of the things I
L about playing uh Archie is that I got
to do something very different from
myself because normally I don't get to
do those things so on Voice work I can
be anything I can sound like anyone they
show you a picture and you go wow I wish
I look like that how great I've played
in the DC Universe for instance I've
been
uh Superman and Rasel G and Le Luther
and Alfred and you know a million people
um so gach was it was not a game i' play
I'm such an addict I can't allow myself
to play video games or else I'd have no
life fabulous artwork and I knew it was
a big game and you
know he's an interesting PL it's a
pretty brutal world it's pretty
darwinian world and you got to try and
survive and so though he's very
manipulative and possibly untrustworthy
and mellan and all those things he's a
Survivor I mean he's he's doing what it
takes to grab power in a power seeking
world and so it was nice to be that
canny manip it felt like he was playing
yo slightly um you know he's he has
power but he wants power and he's got to
play these other people off against each
other yeah it was great it was I mean
you get to not only do you get to do
that stuff unlike on a film said you get
to record a 100 versions of it s
sessions over the course of years they
go away and animate and come back and go
and animate come back and do new things
and other things so you really get to
play and explore and and there are a
million permutations as you play the
game as you'll come across so you get to
feel fully immersed in something I love
video games excellent well thank you so
much I'm glad I got A Sneak that
question in on the end cool excellent
thank you Jason I say hi to Steve I
shall